[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut mon petit ma croûte comme rival
mais la question pourquoi tu parles plus
tu es malade qu'est ce qui t'arrive
je sais pas ce qui m'arrive dès que je
parle j'ai la voix de gilles verdez tu
as pris des médicaments taperait intrus
banon j'ai pris quelque chose mais c'est
pas la gorge on dit à quelqu'un
j'entends dire qu'il ya quelqu'un à tous
pas tous à tous et toi a pour atout
redoute 2 je suis rentré mais ça lui va
merci pour l'accueil ça va qu'est ce qui
lie femme actuelle qu'est-ce qu'il prend
ben quoi j'ai fait tous les tests je
m'ennuie déjà mais là toujours par monts
et par vaux pour john occupe et alors
qu'est ce que dany tu as jamais croire
quoi apparemment je suis clitoridienne
le maître arrive et lui dit c'est l ates
laguna elle a su son patin énuméra van
gogh un saut sabbat c'est quoi la lie en
david bertrand à dîner danser y aurait
plus qu'à ses blagues à lui placé la
jeunesse hays charge de cons ça va
calme-toi csat a tout gagné je me casse
tu verras plus qu'un c'est foutu le
verra encore parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
bien
calme toi comme calme toi
[Musique]